[Music]
[Applause]
we are we're away good afternoon ladies
and gentlemen
yeah apologies we're running late
but if you already will get underway
once murray's
circulated a few things welcome along on
this
sunny waimakariri day i'm not sure what
the temperature is out there but it
doesn't feel like october
all right mr ruben would you be
so kind as to kick off the characters
[Music]
thank you very much um now just to note
that we're still working on our audio
link for our meetings for the rest of
the year so
um please members and if there's any
members of the public
speaking if we can use the microphones
please
apologies i have one from
david ashby he's at a family funeral at
the moment he will try and join us a bit
later on
uh one from stephen bragg
and tim davey
if i can have a mover please that those
are accepted
end sorry i'm john clock news crook oh
and john cook right uh
judah thank you second huh
okay thank you
i'll carry those audio we'll do some uh
introductions to start off the day
uh erin harvey community representative
judith roper lindsay community
representative
sandra stewart waimakariri district
councillor
wendy main community representative
caroline latham community representative
cam henderson community representative
arapata ruben knight representative
um michael blackhall um community
representative and the current chair
and if we can pass the ball down to you
robert you can lead off down the back
thank you
[Music]
thank you everyone
behave do we have any changes to the
registrar of
interest
yeah um remove me as chair of tonight
christchurch mountain
no no no i've taken off
he's still on are you still on the he's
still a wrap but does not check
corbin hello um do we have any members
of the public that would
like to talk today michael
robert
do you guys want to do paper rock
scissors to see who goes first
thank you mr chairman and members of the
design committee
firstly apologies for um gate crashing
half an hour ago
i was a bit ahead of myself last week i
was a bit late
i never got to the oxford drains
committee but nevermind
um yeah look uh just a couple of things
um
firstly you've got good news and bad
news good news is that uh
in the last month there has been
a lot of activity on our river frontage
at vast expense and the bad news is i've
got to spring them a step because i've
got a very much lighter pocket
about eighty thousand dollars it's cost
long overdue 27 years
in fact has taken me to persuade ecam
that
yes there is a problem there i first
presented myself in front of the ecan
council in
1995 and has taken since then with
many presentations and a whole gap of my
time
my life from 98 to low seven when i
retired as a counselor
and during that period of time the ecan
rivers department would not entertain
the idea of doing river protection on my
frontage
because they deemed it was it would
would be perceived as being a conflict
of interest
now that was the thinking then it was
appalling
in the meantime we our family have lost
somewhere between 8 and 10 hectares
200 250 000 worth of land
took me
hiring a lawyer ten thousand dollars to
present myself to the ecan council
a year ago to finally convince them that
yes
they had a responsibility to actually do
something
in previous presentations i'd made
a very disappointing previous
presentations i'd made
i get the letter back we note that
you're concerned about this we know
to get concerned about the other thing
and we know one of those letters had
five things that they noted
but did nothing this time a year ago
the then chairman stephen lowens
he directed chief executive bayfield to
actually
action the problems that i'd outlined
and only then did things start to happen
it took
26 blooming years
now it's 27 years and we've got
something done
but we've lost a lot of land and it's
cost a hell of a lot more
because that's a hell of a lot more than
it would have
which brings me on to the the next thing
your
um
uh what do you call it your vegetation
clearance
from the cookie to the confluence up to
the gorge
now i don't know where that's at
except i've been i was implored to get
on and do the
rib protection before the end of june
so the frontage out
in the middle of the river out from us
could be done at the same time
all those funds can't be carried forward
i don't know what's happened to those
funds but then all of a sudden
there was another half million of funds
arrived from shovel ready stuff
inverted commerce we're told you know
more about it than me
but where where that is in the time
frame i don't know
i'm told it was going to be in october
then i was told it was going to be
november
december
but would you robert you don't spend
your money first
so i have so i've got a clear
expectation that
that that vegetation clearance
out in the far side of the river from
our frontage
will be done um
but when it will be known i don't know
so that's a that's really
my question to you people do you know
have you been advised by eken
as to when that might happen thank you
robert i'm
i'm pleased to hear that you've got some
good news
we will embrace that that's a good start
and i'll ask possibly andrew can you
shed a bit of light on the next program
at the workshop uh we got here today
i've referred to the fact that
we have the driver plan
at the workshop this afternoon i talked
about the draft plan um for the
as in the the action actions being taken
on the actually recording
that is and i'm sorry i'm only reading
that on my phone it was sent to me today
um this work is clearly within that
um and is there what i wouldn't expect
um the zone committee doing
to know the exact dates of that but
we'll find out and inform you of that
simply because it's actually an
operational manner and um
whilst robert has gone through his
sequence of events
there's perhaps other elements and
broader um scheme of
um of the covert funding and things that
are actually having an impact on this
but we can certainly find out the date
and come back
with um with um with a sort of confirmed
date or range date
for that work to be done i have no
reason whatsoever
to doubt that the work will be being
done and what i will term as being the
near future
as and i my understanding it's actually
would have started by this side of
christmas
but that's i'd have to say is from
conversations rather than actual fact
but
there's nothing i've been made aware of
that says there's any delay or any
significant delay in the work to be done
yep so i can find out the date and come
back to the zone committee well that's
that's similar to what i've heard is
that
yes it's been confirmed but uh no no
date's been
been set so that's why i asked a
question
but assuming it it all goes ahead at
some point
could i make a further point that um
this this won't be a one-off now
i'm told that sort of it's coven money
it's shovel ready money
it's one off type money
my point is that someone somewhere
should be keeping their eye on the ball
making sure that there is future funding
set aside or made available or whatever
for the maintenance
of that vegetation clearance
i know it's taking a long time to get to
the it is now
but it won't stay like that you only go
look at the air riverbed
and he can put the bulldozers into that
on a regular basis
to keep it clear
that's the only other point i'd make
possibly
that might be a thought you could put
into ecan's long term plan
are you talking to me or to we act just
for information and mr chairman because
you want there in discussing our
priorities for the long-term plan
actually maintenance of flow
through things like maintaining open
channel
was one of our priorities that we just
identified in the workshop
that you had this afternoon
the other point i'd make is that in the
course of the
works at home
it was pointed out to me that the uh
the bulldozer really wasn't allowed in
the river
for fear that it might uh make the do
make the water a bit muddy
but discoloration
now you know in the big scheme of things
that is just such a load of nonsense
it's not funny
um next week you could get five inches
of rain and the ac
will be a good a good flood it won't be
a raging torrent you've got to get eight
inches around to get a
decent flood but
if you can't do some river protection
works
on the one hand and put the bulldozer
into some water
and make the thing discolored on the
other
well then it's a contradiction of terms
that's the only other point i'd make
somebody somewhere
has got to get some common sense i take
your point robert but
council workers and contractors are
obliged to
try and mitigate any impact they have in
the course of doing those work so
it is a frustrating framework but it
does
take precedence well it's a nonsense
it's an absolute nonsense
they do say the law is an ass but it's
still the law and the
retired judge once said if the laws and
s
change the law
thanks ron
just if we could just no mistake
mr david ashby has rushed to join us
just got a question for robert so robert
what have you because i've had a look at
your
riverbank there and i'm just interested
to know what you've done
and what you're now expecting ecan to do
because i don't know the details of that
well there were two
there were two parts to our problem
um i don't know if you can remember the
the site of the old house that got uh
yeah well the works that have done
upstream of there
there's still major problem below that
old house site with the high cliffs
those 50 foot high cliffs no work's been
done there
um we've concentrated
we've concentrated our efforts with the
where the river changed its flow and it
came in like a great big fish hook
and they've put in these um
oh they've got a name for them too you
know escapes me
the digger hole take a trench anchor
a concrete block for the wire rope and
then put in some some
greenery some willows that are all
lashed together
and then and then another one half a
chain down
and then in between that put in rot
so there's uh nearly 600 tonne of rock
been
brought in and they're good rocks too
they're half the size of this table or
bigger
they're not pebbles that'll float away
so there's a there's a lot of rock gone
in in these
rock groins in between these uh
plantings
which are anchored with a dead man away
back in the paddock
and wire ropes it's actually um i'm very
impressed because i hadn't
seen this concept before or
heard of it and uh the
david owen and fred brooks the
or david's in the behind the desk i
think and fred brooks is the
man organizing it he they uh
introduced this concept to me of the
protection type of protection that they
had in mind
and so i really took them on faith
and i'm glad i did because uh i'm very
impressed
i'm very impressed
so yes it's a lot of money
uh as long overdue we could have spent
a lot less money 10 years ago
um but anyway that's history we've done
it now
we've got to hope and pray that what
they've done is
will hold we'll survive the
first test and we haven't had it
we haven't had a test in that river
since the end of july
that very terrible bad friday
i remember it well
so and then further up
they have put in a uh
a couple of concrete a couple of shingle
banks and fred brooks
proudly said robert i'll put you in the
truck and come and show you
your the the johnston memorial wall
[Laughter]
cheeky burger anyway
they're there to help i don't know how
long they'll last
because that river in full fury can be
vicious
so for the first time in the zone's
history of my attendance
i've got a smile on the face
thank you very much
michael jordan
there we go
right at the top
today i'm going to talk about the cam
from northbrook road down
there's actually no wheat in the river
at all
and no mechanical thing done there at
all it's all planted
there's a good cave here plants
everywhere all native plants
not a bit of weed in the river never saw
a bully never saw an eel never saw a
trout
there's actually no biodiversity in the
tour next one please murray
this is a close-up of it
same as the taranaki stream just rolling
sand and sediment
from rotten vegetation next one please
murray
all nicely planted again no weed
why why can't we do something about it
the nutrients there's nitrates in the
water
that should be prolific weed should be
smothered in wheat
not no weed next one please murray
that he has had a tree pulled out on
that one
in the last 12 months next one please
murray
same scenario next one
and this is at bramley's bridge i'm
sorry about the glare on the water but
the sun wasn't out the day was there
you can see patches of oxygen wheat
growing in the water
next one please murray that's a close-up
of it
how can we get it to grow there when we
can't get it to grow further up the camp
next one please this is at rebels road
very little weed in the water it's been
like that for
two years a very slight improvement last
summer why
there's nothing else will kill that but
chemicals unless it's been mechanically
dug out
i'm sick to death coming here all the
time
showing you things and nothing ever
happens excellent please murray
that's further down the cam there's a
wee tiny bit of weed
and if you scoop in the weed there is
the odd shrimp there an not bully
carry on murray
that should be full of weed
nothing next one
just go down the river and just gets
no betting and see we could weed see
that sand and rolling
the same scenario everywhere you go
next one
just being mud you go there at night
there's hardly a bully
virtually no biodiversity at all
excellent
that's behind the mill
2016 that was full of weed
next one please murray now this is over
at the courtney stream
not a bit of weed in it
used to be willow trees there next time
that's what it was like before it was
trees were cut out the trees were taken
out about two years ago
not a bit of weed in the thing you go
upstream
next one please worry
this is the same stream further up this
is what it should look like
grass growing out on the water making
cover for our biodiversity
i'm not saying the water's perfect
because it won't be the nitrates will be
up in it
that's what our stream should look like
the can should look like that
next one please
this is further up see the watercress
six foot wide
this was only taken two weeks ago
this is what the cam should look like
that's what all our strengths should be
looking like
i'm too scared to tell you because it'll
disappear
uh it's up the courtney stream right at
the top greg's road
next one please
it's a close up for the watercress
healthy
next one please marry
there's oxygen weed in the water and
other weeds
virtually 100 weed
this is a shocker this is the botanical
gardens right in the middle of the
botanical gardens a middle bridge
not a bit of weed in it nothing
i know someone's done a survey of fish
life and the trout kneels
down low in numbers i don't know who
done it because i heard the public
talking about it
next one please
that's just off the bridge just walking
to go to see a specialist at the vld
hospital and this is what you come up
against
next one another view look
what annoys me there's no life there i
couldn't find a bully or nothing
i did see two trout and one eel in the
places i looked next one please marry
now this is at pendleton road right on
the edge of the road
only two k's upstream maybe two and a
half k's
100 weed
you know downstream should be similar
what's going on why can't we get to the
bottom and i know this is not in our
district
this is just an example to show you
this is what how prolific the trout used
to be this is about the 1960s
early 60s this is one pool in the
southern river
when it dried up
now you'd be lucky we saw one there
i want the zone committee to get someone
to look into this and find get to the
bottom of it
i'm sick as i'm saying it's just
sediment stopping the wheat from growing
because that's blatantly not true
these rivers have been here for millions
of years
and they've put up with a hell of a lot
of sediment over that time
any questions
linda michael i'm
just wondering my recent experience in
oxford
is a very tidy gardener neighbour of
mine
who was spraying out the ditch in front
of her property
with weak killer now
in my previous life the one thing i did
come across
was the synergistic effect of toxins
on plants and animals in water and
you don't need a toxic amount
of weed killer of copper or
zinc if you have just a micro amount
of each one the combined effect
is going to give you a kill
and i'm wondering if one of the reasons
that the authorities are up against is
they can't control my tidy neighbor
and the runoff from so many
small streams feeding into these bigger
rivers
may just be collecting minute quantities
of various things that would kill off
the plants
and what is needed is a public
information
campaign as much as an
investigation um i guess
from your information you must have been
able to
track back the
confluence of rivers that are dirty or
rather the conflicts of rivers
or streams that have got life in them
with those where it's completely gone
um it's not completely gone but okay
one or two percent left what should we
do yes
a lot of drains run out you can see
where they run out they kill the weak
for about a meter out for about 20
meters and it gets diluted enough it
doesn't come away
yeah but to kill the whole river
it's not going to run in one drive but
can you identify
where those harmful substances
are actually entering the river in some
places you can
see where it stops and starts the
river's
perfect and nothing there's no drain
running
where the authorities ought to be
looking towards speaking to these people
the whole school's been running brown
for three years the wheat comes back in
the summer time of that
then by the mid winter down to bma
and then it rolls it had hundreds of
thousands of dollars worth of
plants going in there been there for 15
years some of them
i mean hundreds of thousand dollars
miles of it
no difference to the river whatsoever
i'm just trying to think you know
cheaper solutions than having a big
investigation which is requiring budget
money
at the end of the day what do we think
of our environment if we're not prepared
to spend a bit of money on it
test the sediment in the bottom of them
and find out what's in it
not rocket science well i think the
other thing that
needs to be put forward is the
biodiversity in the water
is an indicator of the overall health of
the water
which is ultimately what we're drinking
another one is the um capertoni stream
about four k's but not a bit of weed in
it
that's that's behind belfast michael yep
yep and there's a big
pond in there between the two
[Music]
the um stix river and the capitoni
stream
it's about 200 meters long about 100
meters wide
not a bit of weed in it another
indication there's hundreds and hundreds
of native trees planted all around it
been there for 10 15 years
no weed water running into it the
creek's running into it
no weed in them
thank you michael um mr chair i wonder
if we could
ask um adrian at the next meeting to
give us a presentation on
just weed habitat requirements in rivers
um
you know i'm conscious that with all the
sediment i mean one of the reasons for
doing sediment trapping is to
is to actually give the native weed
um things to hold on to um you know
physically not to get washed away and
and in initiating sediment that moves
you know there are certain habitat
requirements so just a
perhaps a short briefing on um good
weeds bad weeds and why we don't have
weeds
um in our waterways well it's
aquatic plant life that's what we need i
don't care what sort of plant life but
as long as well that's what i'm saying
yeah
just why isn't anything growing
even the buddies yeah no take that on
one thank you
that's rebels road in the cam and behind
two or here were you those good pitchers
i showed you
that's what the cam used to be like when
i was a kid used to go right across
now there's none there
it's not farming causing it i'll tell
you that now
so if you've got any thoughts you want
to put forward at short notice
i think it'd be quite good to to
actually map the areas where you're
seeing the
the weed beds dying off and yeah just
looking at overlaying with management
um if there's you know i it could be
multiple factors but you know there
could be patterns that
could emerge from that most of the areas
he can have got control of them not that
i met district council
where it's bad yeah so it could be a
maybe support from me can to to map that
what you're seeing
or wdc is that yeah
student project good student project
yeah so just thinking about
or is it something i mean obviously we
could you know with a highlighter you
can also just take a map of the district
and highlight it that could be
sophie i i do believe most of it's been
mapped right down to as far as rebels
wrote
um through all that cam river
rehabilitation work that's been done for
the last 20 years
it's been well mapped it's well known
what the issues are we actually
we actually got a plan in place but no
one's implementing it
that's the big problem so my question is
not to michael it's actually to the
council an
environment canterbury just get on and
do it
otherwise we're just rehashing old stuff
yeah sorry
sandra yes you're right um
the cam fund has yet to spend any money
it's been sitting there for 20 years
we can't do anything in stream because
he can we're waiting on the eq and
consent
um i'm having an update on where that is
this week
and so until we get um
the tick off to do uh any of the network
which
involves many many sediment traps
um in the um in the brooks and
not down to the main stem
not below bramley's but upstream
i mean i i have an answer
for you um until the work's done
and we won't see any results on the
sediment and that's to tackle
the sediment i mean the as michael
correctly
identifies there's a lot of planting but
that really
um deals to
a cross-ground run off and
trying to filter that out but it doesn't
deal with
um critical source areas where sediment
is pouring in
and there is a lot of as henry hudson
identified
hundreds if not thousands of tonnes of
legacy sediment sitting in that um
those brooks and that's that river um
having an answer for
um why some of it has um is growing weed
even under those conditions and
others aren't and it would be good to to
map the areas and see whether they
they change at various times of the year
certainly welcome that but you know as
far as spending any money
as yet still waiting on a consent
with the increaser with the increase in
nitrates in the water
point nine is a winner
environment canterbury be four weeks ago
now on the escort river
and no reply yet just to sit they say
they've received it
now that's the worst of the lot and it's
got more planting than anything else
the nitrates in there about three point
eight to four
it should be prolific aquatic weed life
in there
it used to be when i fished it
like farming you put more nitrates on or
more fertilizer on the more grassy road
same in the water until it gets two
seconds and kills it i guess
treatment plant andrew did you want to
add please come up and use the
microphone
yep now's a good time
um first one actually
so in regards to the consent we were
asked at the last
committee meeting to give an update on
where that was at we looked into that
the response has been supplied
the reality is the consent has gone back
and forth back and forth
um and as i understood a window it got
was updated it wasn't the ball wasn't in
our court but i don't think that consent
is very far off being granted
at the moment so it's it has actually
gone back and forth and back and forth
within a period of time so it's not all
with environment canterbury um
i know it's i've just got the update
about what it was and it's information
from both sides providing information or
not providing information that's
actually delayed
their process um
and then the other one which robert's
dot here but i'll make sure update there
is that
regarding that work in the upper
ashley so the covert funding that came
through
the process then is that the government
supplies a letter to us to confirm that
that's just been has just been received
within the next 30 days they supply a
contract for that work to be done
that means we can then start our
procurement process which we have to
abide by that takes a couple of months
so all of a sudden you're at christmas
they would be then be evaluated it may
be before christmas but let's say it's
in
um january which would actually say that
it's sort of that february mid february
march before the work starts so that
process there that we're talking about
as government central government process
followed by a procurement process that
we have to go through
just like all councils do for every
process so that's the update that i can
give on that and i'll make sure that
robert gets to hear that
right going back to the degraded state
of our lowland waterways
um i agree with you michael that the
photos that you present
each month when you can uh the greatest
uh illustration of what we're trying to
correct
and it's a abort the condition that
we're looking at
um and look there is no single answer
but
yeah well i've been fishing for 55 years
i've spent my whole life on waterways
and i won't even buy a license now no no
and and there's a lot of others
one thing you dig a hole to catch a
sediment it's not going to fix it
because that's not the problem
sediment's not the problem
but not the soul it's only a problem
because there's no aquatic weed in the
river
aquatic weed in the river catches the
sediment and the weed grows through it
and it builds up and builds up
yep all right any further question to
michael
oh okay sorry just just one michael um
you
quite often present um photos of
situations outside of our zone
predominantly in the christchurch area
do you also present this to the
christchurch west melbourne zone
committee
is that an option once a month is enough
for me
i don't mind doing it it's not a problem
we don't want to see something
constructive and done it doesn't have to
be a lot of money to fix these things
we've got to use a bit of common sense
you drive around all around canterbury
half the drains are all sprayed it's not
doing the biodiversity any good
so with regard to your sprain it comes
back to linda's point which
she's quite correct it's how do you stop
your neighbour doing what they think is
their right so we come back but now we
come back to behavioural change and
education
and that's not a fast process personally
i think any any drain or any ditch or
any creek that's got water in it
should be controlled by one body with
input from councils
and farmers and you're not allowed to
touch that drain unless you get the okay
to do so
that's the only way to stop it i know
it's more of the red tape and more
rubbish
but if we can't trust people to look
after our waterways that's what we're
gonna have to do to fix them
robert could i make a comment on that
subject
um you're probably quite right that you
can't trust people to look after these
rights
uh in the early 90s
the oxford rural grain network was of
shambles
and the former man janice skur asked me
to
lead the formation of a oxford rural
drainage committee
which i did and that has been
and and we set up a new rating district
uh which was widely supported by the
community where the
where the drainage network is there's
two
there's one up near you hill quick
street and one
around the foothills of oxford uh
that has been a huge success
and no one's allowed to touch those
drones
without the approval of the oxford
drainage committee
and the drainage committee do it
and that it's paid for by this rate a
drainage rate
but there's some that are designated
within the scheme
and they're only in the scheme because
we don't want anyone to touch them
because to touch them will accelerate
erosion
and the in the city that goes downstream
so it can be done but uh
the my view is that uh
and the guana council had a
new improved or a seminar on
the new improved ways of managing the
rural drains
and one of them was to leave him alone
and let nature take its course
unfortunately that won't happen that one
that's not the solution at some point
you're better to actually manually or
physically
clean them out but spraying is not the
answer
thank you rob anything else michael
i think i said enough today thank you
look we appreciate your time
and your comments sir keep up the good
work
um item three
supora would you like to make a small
presentation please
to present before i launch into that i
thought i'd just give you a three second
update on
the last time we allocated funding we
allocated funding towards three wetlands
and within the last two weeks we've had
contractors
out on the ground beginning those works
because it's now spring
and that can happen so that's um yeah so
that the money we allocated last time
things are starting to move with those
projects which is
very exciting it's all the paperwork's
out of the way
so of this financial year we've
allocated
eight and a half k towards the old
wetland
which is um one of the wetlands down by
kaiapoi
and the rest is currently unallocated
and i'm proposing we allocate
10k that towards the project i'm about
to present
i was hoping to have another project it
was all scoped up and then the nps
landed and
we're still deciding whether the way
we'd scoped it now meets the new wetland
rules
or not so i will hopefully have that to
you next meeting
once we've done a bit more head
scratching and walking around it
and figuring out where fences go
so this project is an ewell it's one of
the largest remaining kanuka remnants
on the plains
so you can see it just there it's um up
from the waimakariri
and it's about 13 hectares it has had
some historic bulldozing
through it you can see those nice
straight lines that nature grows
and that was probably done um for
sheep's shelter
which apparently was the dumb thing back
in the day um
but this canoe remnant would have been
quite representative of what was
originally in this area
so it's quite special it's got
obviously the kanuka that's the sort of
keystone species but it has a whole
suite of um
underground mosses along the ground it's
got a couple of awkward species
colitis um
yeah and a whole lot of other really
rare and exciting
species um some of them are quite pretty
and some of them you do have to kind of
get down on your hands and knees and
forage around but
to have so many native species
you know surrounded by such high
productive land that's been persisting
there
is really exciting um
and also we've done a botanical survey
we haven't done insects
and lizards but we suspect that all the
plant species have been there and
they've been
they've never been lost so we suspect it
was also supporting all the associated
other parts of that ecosystem i got
asked about if we've done a fungi
species today
we haven't looked at fungi but
apparently kanuka remnants
have some of the highest diversity of
fungi as an ecosystem type
so like i said this project is asking
for 10k and six dollars
um and that will be matched by doc um
with slightly more
um so it's the canoe remnants quite
invaded by both ghosts and brew
and that's an issue because they fix
nitrogen
and these are dryland remnants that have
low traditionally very low nutrients
and so by fixing that nitrogen they
allow other exotic species in
um and the other issue is cot's foot
which
is an exotic grass and it responds
really well to a bit of extra
uh irrigation and a bit of extra
nutrients
so the weed control will focus on gauss
broom
and cot's foot control so some selective
spraying and cutting a pasting
and we've also had a lot of success in
another and caribbean
bulldozing around the outside and so
we'll do a scrape alongside this one to
see whether we can start growing
that remnant out again
yeah so that was a short one today and
that's
all i have
is there any questions
um just a question about the irrigation
it does have irrigation right around it
does this block get irrigated
no so it's not it doesn't get irrigated
on um part of the
colts foot issue is water moving along
the ground so they are looking
at trailing sort of digging a ditch and
putting it rocks and see we can get that
to dive rather than go across
yeah so it's not irrigated on but it is
still impacted
[Music]
this particular species of kanuka does
form a closed canopy cover at about four
meters
in this situation yeah yeah so you get
the
canopy cover of kanuka and then you get
some of the other shrubs growing
underneath it and then under that you
get the herbs and the orchids and things
like that
yes it's it is replacing itself so the
trees themselves
i i can't answer that but i wouldn't
expect there'd be
hundreds of years old but yeah they need
to
have that continuous link to things
being there yeah
okay all right one more question ongoing
maintenance obviously this is a bit of a
clean out get rid of all the stuff we
don't want
um ongoing maintenance what's the plan
there yeah so
um doc will do ongoing monitoring of the
site and ongoing maintenance to make
sure that it
doesn't get re-invaded and once you get
those
so the cotswood and the gorsum broom is
really in those doze lines where there's
a lot of light and so we're hoping once
we get the recruitment
and a bit of shade that'll it'll
eventually be a self-sustaining
ecosystem that
won't need a lot of weeding yeah
rodeo so we have a recommendation that
an allocation of
thousand and six dollars john that six
dollars isn't for your coffee is it
ten thousand sorry yeah ten thousand six
where did you get the six dollars oh it
was
so doctored all the numbers and so we
were just um we got some contractors
sorry
yeah okay let me start again yeah an
allocation of ten thousand and six
dollars of ims funding
for the matu kanuka week control project
do i have a mover
judith seconder
sandra all those in favor
any against
one against you again you know caroline
thank you
yep carried
thank you very much thank you
sorry yes you're welcome too
[Music]
um well i mean i don't i obviously think
that it looks like
an awesome canoe shrubland and that it
should be protected
um but i guess my concern is mainly um
on principle
just in that we are providing 10 of our
total
annual ims fund to department of
conservation our government department
whose responsibility it is to protect
biodiversity on dock lands
you know 10 grand is as a drop in the
bucket of their wheat and pest control
budget
but it's a tenth of our whole fund um
so you know i just feel like doc need to
come to the party and do the work
themselves so that we can use our fund
for other community and private
landowner projects that need a helping
hand
that's my only objection
can i ask is it on dockland or is it in
private yes no sorry there's a dock
block in the middle of it
when the dairy farm was sold doc
they did a subdivision so that just that
little block is now in
ownership as a scientific reserve um so
doc have purchased the land
and put a new fence around it but
they're missing obviously a little bit
of funding to do
the initial weed control so chances are
if it had been sold the center pivot
would be going straight through that
whole area now
thank you very much
audio item 4 the macintosh bend rock
protection
update who's presenting that in
yeah please come forward
excuse me um murray um can we ask
um i don't know i know some of the agree
if we can have a
um an idea of those other ims projects
you're working with
even though they're not ready just when
we've got a
funding like this 10 it would be nice to
know what else was in the pipe work in
case we found this and then
something comes up that we would have
liked to use
yeah it would be good for us all to know
for these situations
thank you
right here the floor is yours
thank you come along and talk about this
project
um it's a pretty key bit of flood
protection infrastructure we need to
improve
on the waimakariri river
can i move it over here
yes sir uh you can move it on thanks
murray
i'll hold on to this be right so
um
in essence the goal of the presentation
today is to explain
what this particular project's about
thank you
the need for the project it's content
and timing
and look at the costs
we need to talk about the environmental
and recreational effect management
because it's
reasonably significant engineering job
and also to seek advice on community
consultation
needs and ideally get some zone
committee support for the project
thank you so uh just to summarize
the thing in a couple of slides
mcintosh's band is
particularly sharp band with
exceptionally deep scout hole on the
outside
radius of it there's a there's a risk of
riverbank and stop bank erosion during
flood
and um there's a greater risk of
stopping breach at macintosh's bend than
elsewhere on the waimakariri river at
the moment so it's really a
an issue we need to address a kaipoy
town and the rural surrounds
and the oxidation bonds are all
vulnerable in the event of breakout at
that location
um thank you murray and
we're talking about a 3.2 million dollar
project it's one of the shovel ready
projects that the the government's been
promoting
and so we've been working very hard to
try to get on
get it on the front foot and bring it
forward in essence
in terms of works program start in
december and finish in july
2021 and we need to manage the work
around recreational and
activities and public safety of course
is a major priority as well
so just into this the location of
macintosh's bend or macintosh's rock or
rocks or it's got a variety of different
names
and it's one of the sharpest bins we've
got on the waimakari river and it's
the narrowest point we've got on the
waimakari river so it's a real
bottleneck
you go on from the murray thanks
uh looking a little bit of the big
picture the waimakariri river catchment
is
a fairly large catchment sourced in the
alps and very much dominated by
uh northeast rainfall patterns they're
the events that produce the flood event
floods in the waimakariri
and the river's been trained in inverted
commas
um really ever since the 1870s has been
a little bit of a battle going on
um and you can see that top left-hand
photo
flooding through the square in
christchurch essentially in 1868.
um 1927 that's what the riverbed looked
like
through that mclean's island coots
island and
kaiapoy island area and then the one
below shows
how it was altered over the period to
much more confined with with stop banks
and the breakouts in this direction to
the north
down the old north branch of the
waimakariri what were
we cut off with stop banks thank you
murray
and that's the flood hazard that they
were then we still are trying to manage
so
those are the potential breakout
locations where the arrows are
and and the orange indicates
the potential flood areas if the river
was to get out
and the orange lines there show the
extent of our stock banking network
um up the ear river
the um custom the cam rivers
the waimakariri and the kaiapoi
of course as well
so focusing back on macintosh's band we
have
fury road deer coming down along the
edge of the oxidation ponds
the stop banks are in orange again and
the thing that makes river engineers and
probably anybody else looks at that for
a short time
very nervous is the fact that we've got
a very very narrow
room area here at the end of fury road
very narrow separation between
the riverbank and the stock bank itself
and given that it's on a particularly
sharp bend as well
there's a very high risk of the
riverbank eroding the boomerading the
stopbank eroding and floodwaters
escaping thank you
uh in the 1960s
in the catchment board era there was uh
heavy rock armoring put along that
riverbank and here's a
a beautiful set of construction drawings
that they had at the time
so that so that rock's largely still
there
having been topped up over the years
with blood damage and
to some extent with the earthquake
damage that occurred as well
um but it's not the whole answer
unfortunately
and in more recent times we we
have looked at the band much more
closely so we have
cross sections that we surveyed five
yearly cycles on those red lines
so you can see two cross sections across
the river there could you go forward one
please murray and i'll come back
so um that shows the cross sections
plotted looking downstream with the stop
bank the bump on the left
coming across the boom down into the
channel and up and over
so the the um the one with the deepest
bead level is the red line and it's down
to
nine meters below mean sea level but if
you compare it with the cross sections
upstream and downstream of that location
they're only down about three to four
meters below
mean sea level so it's uh there's a very
deep scale hole on the outside of that
bend
if you go back again please murray just
back one yeah that's right
so so the other thing we did was
riverbed soundings
and um the area in blue there is the
area where the scout hole is the deepest
right where the fishermen prefer this
fish i think
and and um that's
uh deeper than minus nine that's c minus
12 that's 12 meters
below mean sea level compared to three
meters below sea level
um upstream and downstream in the rural
beds so it's a very very very deep scale
hole
here going thanks murray so so
this is what the site looks like in in
fair weather with the fishermen and the
fishing platform there which is a which
is a key spot
so you can see the rock armoring along
the riverbank it's
it's um not quite as tidy as we'd like
it to be it's not going to perform quite
as well as we'd like it to in a big flat
event
um if you go on just one more murray
and and in behind the stop being that
excess track
is uh also quite vulnerable to local
scour and erosion which could out flat
out flank the rock line from behind so
this is this is what the river looked
like about half a meter below the peak
in november 2018 which was a minor flood
it was really a minor flood in the
scheme of things
um but you can see the turbulence out
there where the deep water is
and you can see how the water's jumping
the rock line and and um
moving quite fast even and behind it the
debris that's powered up there is
against the uh fishing platform
uh railing you can go on one more so
that's not a big flood that's a that's
only half of our design flood in terms
of flow
so there's a whole variety of things
going on at macintosh's bend that you
can
see there on that list stop stop flood
protection infrastructure if you like
drainage out falls feldwicks and
macintoshes
kaipoi town and behind it the ox station
ponds nearby
and then we come down into the the other
values the regional park the pegasus
walkway
fishing wetlands all around that area
and in boating
now this is a contour plan of of that
flood plain area
and um murray could you point out
macintosh's bend for us on on there so
yeah that that's it right on so so if
if the stop bang breach is there in a
major flood
it could get in it'll certainly get
beyond the yellow and the orange
and it'll it'll get into the into that
purple
so it's beginning to affect the
outskirts outskirts of kaipoy
um we're hopeful that if it got out
there it would be reasonably well
contained in that bubble
but certainly to be localized flooding
all around that bubble
thank you
so what we are suggesting um
at this stage and it's interim works in
a sense
um in that there'll still be longer term
investigation work to do perhaps
to try to deal with the sharpness of the
bend and the depth of the scale hole but
in the interim we feel we can get huge
gain by
a combination of riverbank
rock armor strengthening making the
access trek behind that
along that riverbank much more resilient
to scour and erosion
and then going back to the red line
there along the top of the stop bank
um placing a rock lining along the stop
bank
side slope and and keying that into the
ground
um two meters or so deep so that so that
uh there's much dislike the other of the
stop being getting washed out
due to erosion um
yeah before you go off off that murray
uh
we've we've worked particularly hard to
try to
sequence all of this works so that has
minimal effect on the
people using the area in particular
fishermen
and so if you can see the numbers
there uh number one
is is essentially at the end of fury
road there we need to do some car park
enhancement there to create more car
parks during construction
so that people can still park and use um
we need to do a lot of localized fencing
in that area so we can separate
trucks and excavators from people
and um over in the paddock
just to the left of fury radio we need
to develop a site office and an area to
stockpile rocks so that we can
the rocks coming in from viewport
quality over at oxford it's about 70
kilometers away
so it'll have to be unloaded off the
truck and trailers and then put on to
off-road
uh vehicles to to cart down to site to
place
so so moving on to site number two is
where that blue dash line is on the left
hand side
that's an access track upgrade along the
edge of
that wetland and uh and then we move
through to
gee you as it is it's a bit hard to see
isn't it some additional rock
lighting work in the orange there which
is just at the coyote river confluence
and um yeah that's right that's right
and then we move up to up to three which
is stop bank rock armoring
um on the
western side of fury road so that's
number three the murray on the red
no up top next one up that's right and
then number four
is the same thing on the other side of
fury road and
um and then five is uh
some of that blue or six or some of that
blue arm ring work
um yeah i've lost that now
yep number six there five and six there
and then seven seven eight and nine is
where we were affecting the fisherman
and and
[Music]
to avoid overlap with the fishing
seasons
and even when we do slightly overlap we
we've got the ability for fishermen to
go either
downstream or upstream of that ferry
road area
so essentially the fishing platform the
wheelchair platform that's there
is the pivot point for access either
either side
so you can go on from that nail murray i
think
so so so the point i'm making really is
that we've worked very very hard to try
to
separate out our activities from from
the local
recreational use
so that that in essence summarizes some
of the key activities that i've just
talked about
we're about 20 000 tonnes of graded rock
that we need to bring in
and um that comes in by trucking trailer
from oxford as i said
so that's 27 ton per truck and trailer
load so if you divide 27 into 20 000
that gives you a number i'm
not quite sure what that is
and one of the key elements of it is
widening the access track
over the stock bank so that we can
have enough room to separate trucks from
people and have a lane way for people to
walk over
we need to have a we need to allow our
access along a pegasus walkway
cycle way for as long as we can and we
can do that by putting the cycle way
down into the adjoining paddock
through the district council land
increase the ferry road car park area as
i mentioned before
and one of the little by-products of
what we're doing is i notice at the
moment that a lot of fishermen stand out
on those rocks
so they can get a big better reach and
they're wobbling away there while they
do that well
hopefully they'll wobble a little bit
less but we certainly wouldn't want to
be encouraging them to do that
um go on here
and uh this is what the stock bank rock
armory looks like
at the bottom that sketch picture so
we're we're starting the rock armor
layer about a meter from the top of the
stop bank coming down the side
to to berm level and then we are keying
in two meters below boom level
and we need to put a water barrier under
that to reduce the seepage
path and seepage through the stop bank
but it's mainly about erosion resistance
and we've another thing we've worked
very hard on is trying to limit the
amount of that work we need to do
adjacent to the
to the wetland areas thank you murray
and his here's a picture of the rock
lining um you can see
in that wet area that certainly a track
enhancement is going to be a big
improvement for everybody
here again we're working adjacent to
wetlands
in one or two locations in particular
and we've got to take care to
not to affect the control the water
level controls in those wetlands so
maintain the ability for water to go in
and out in the way that
they've developed naturally thanks
murray
and in terms of tree removal we've got
uh willow trees would probably crack
willows we need to remove from the rock
arnold
riverbank in places
and also that particular tree we need to
remove in order to widen the excess ramp
over the stop bank
to allow that space we've talked about
before
yeah and
in terms of environmental works we've
talked about the weird willows
uh we need to do some flex planting
along the edge of choccy baker creek
and the stop being tow we need to
maintain the wetlands and put
and and improve or maintain the
hydraulic connections that's essential
and retain or relocate
native trees and by that i mean flaxes
mainly
we were disturbing them we've allowed in
the
in the overall estimate of 3.2 million
and 80 000
allowance for environmental enhancements
so we were open
to office as to how we could
constructively use that that money
and public safety is also very high
so um just go through
i won't go through that list in detail
but it's about managing people and
around the car park
the walkway over the ramp to the fishing
site
and also the walkway along the stop bank
yeah and
you won't be able to read that but it
essentially shows
the the project broken down into its
various activities
and how it starts off in construction
starts off in
december um and that's essentially
enabling work and getting established
and and then starting with more of a
vengeance
in late january and into february and
then carrying on through to
early july so
the orange lines at the bottom are
my understanding of the white bait
fishing season
the brown trout sea run and the salmon
fishing seasons
and so as i said before we've we've
tried to
be as sympathetic as we can with those
with the timing of those
activities
yeah thank you murray so um
that's just a picture of the view hall
quarry so it's a good place to stop i
think thank you
if i may um in terms of as a resident of
the kaipoy north area
my query looking i just pulled up a map
was what roads were the trucks going to
be using
because lee's road if that's the way
it's going to come in
and then to clifford and then down to
fury it's not really suitable for
that many heavy trucks
we're talking we're talking line side
road coming in line side road to beach
road here here
yep so what's the road that goes off to
oxford from long side road
um i just forget the name of it
yeah so is any consideration been given
to
those smaller roads that may require
some
repair work after the trucks have been
down after the project's finished
or is that left to the wymac district
council as their regular maintenance
or even or even quantities really it
sounds like
20 000 sounds like a lot but but
there's nothing particularly unusual
about it um we've we've
for the waimakariri flood protection
project that we've just completed
we carted something like 260 260 000
tons
from oxford to the waimakariri river
upstream of the motorway
and on north side and south side and
placed that so
it didn't have any drama around road
maintenance
no complaints from district council
absolutely right raising that it but um
it's perhaps part of the longer term
solution
um what we're proposing now will be
compatible with anything we do in the
future and we'll add value to anything
we do in the future
but it'll take us i think uh quite some
years and much bigger budget
to do the sort of um solution you're
suggesting
and and and yet absolutely right it's
it's the um
siltation of the inside of that bend and
the migration
of the channel across that's it's
creating a lot of that pressure
um but that's actually
sort of two degrees of difficulty
more complicated than what we're talking
about now in terms of getting to that
point could
take us years and years and years to
actually figure out what
what's this quick thing to do there and
how to do it
and we'd still we
we would still need to do what we're
proposing to do now you see so
so um you know i'm i'm not saying that
that longer-term thinking doesn't need
to happen it will happen
um but just keep in mind that everything
we're proposing here it will be
compatible with
anything else that's rolled out in
what you're doing future yeah well they
they may not love us while we're there
that's right so so by keeping it over
here and redirecting it
you're ready you know these massive
holes for salmon anyway so it's pretty
cool but
i'm just thinking the longer term
because you just if you shoot it out
you've only got to see where the river
rang
because it runs right over that gray but
it all didn't it went right out there
yeah and it also ran over the bit that's
got the weak
and that's exactly why i started off the
way i did start off
in terms of yeah there is a bigger
picture
um
it'd be quite a challenge to actually
work out what needs to be done
and have the confidence and that's going
to be the answer and then get all the
consents to do it
i don't think many people realize that
this river is an amazing river
you know at some stage flow through the
middle of christchurch float out through
lake ellsman it's been a long
bloody show that river yeah and you know
we're controlling it by keeping it
within stock
robert you're in the dark i can't even
see you
well that's great but that opens up the
wider question
of the other issue that i have been
hammering the table for for
the last 20 years and that is the
and it should be the the reintroduction
of the central government's boat soil
and water
and the reformation of the soil
conservation rivers control
council which disappeared in the
in the restructuring of local government
in 1989 slash 90
because vote soil and water was was a
bipartisan thing
didn't matter which government was in
red or blue uh they still had a vote
soil at water it
went winston
new esco and they allocated the money
out for catching boards
and since the very early 90s there has
been no
central government funding for regional
councils
with the exception of the very very bad
floods there's been a couple of them in
there too there was one up at edcom
and i think a couple more one on the
west coast perhaps have got a wee bit of
funding
but i think the all councils
regional councils throughout new zealand
and the zones
should be making noises about the
reinstatement
of central government funding for that
this this project shouldn't have to rely
on
on pre-election shovel-ready money
the vegetation clearance in the ashley
shouldn't have to rely on shovel-ready
money
that's not a long-term solution but
the very interesting presentation but
um and thank you thank you erin sorry
i'm i'm going to put my mum safety hat
on now
um just having a look at the roads that
you're proposing to use
so they're within 300 metres of kaiboy
north school which is a very large
school
and there are a lot of children that
cross smith and beach road
between 8 30 and 9 and 3 and 3 30.
so is there any consideration to the
timing of the heavy vehicles
to avoid the schools
they can be the these are issues we work
through with
once we've um completed the tender
process
and got a preferred contractor these are
the sort of things we sit down with them
and talk to them about
and so um
it's it's two two trucks per hour sort
of thing
over quite a long period of time and and
so it's
yeah yes exactly and and and uh
yeah yeah yeah understood so a lot a lot
of it's about
selecting the right contract and we
certainly plan to do that
and he he ensures that he has good
drivers and we all ensure that they're
well briefed and they're following their
instructions
and and with other schools um i think
with past works we had a much lower
speed limit
past past those schools than what we had
elsewhere yeah i mean it's not directly
past the school but it is past
the main one of the main roads between
the school
and some of the zone that that the
children come from
so it would just be about maybe noting
that in your discussion with the
contractor
you've got quite a deep hole there
developing already how much deeper does
it need to get before it starts
undermining the arm ring there
the the rock armor that's there has been
settling down into that hole so as it's
been topped up from the top it's been
sliding in from the bottom
um it's part of this bigger picture
as mentioned before as to but
we're reasonably comfortable at the
moment that it's in as good a state it
can be in other than going in with rock
armor and filling the hole
and then we've got to have a discussion
with the fishermen and an ecologist
around that
so so you know um yeah it's
we can't be 100 confident that that
isn't going to undermine and
and cause trauma that's why we're doing
the work it's all about risk management
and trying to manage these uncertainties
um
thank you um i'm just interested in the
wetlands as you mentioned
they you um you just said you would
limit you know
affected them to a limited extent and i
wasn't quite sure how to what extent you
are affecting the wetlands and
give your
project resource consent and and also
our code of practice guidelines for
operating these sort of areas so yeah so
um
we've actually limited the extent of the
rock work we're doing to try to avoid
the
the worst overlaps on the one hand
but we will be working on the margin so
it's all about stopping sediment from
getting in
working from the stock bank rather than
working from there
none of the actual um rock work is
actually going to go into the wetland i
mean are you actually reducing not
reducing they're not reducing
the size of eating well the one or two
wish
that people may define as wetlands that
are very shallow and ephemeral
and we and if we're if we're going to
reduce the
size of those we'll we'll move we'll
create the same equivalent area
further out so so we've got to recreate
what we had before yeah
just with the and again the new national
policy statement um
wetlands become a very tricky thing to
deal with to touch at all
and that might affect your world i
won't comment on that because do you
want to go there
yep okay there was the other thing just
related to that was you've got
um having uh in the engineers uh uh
capable and
i can't remember the phrase a good
contractor and i just
wonder if that also has to be in the
criteria for the environmental side that
the contractor is
you know capable and competent in the
environmental area you know doesn't just
drive his truck through
the wetland by accident or something
like that yeah just to
raise the protection level there oh
that's that that's all part of our
standard
practice it really is yeah it really is
okay ian thank you for a very thorough
presentation
um yeah definitely hitting the right
track
[Laughter]
that's confidential it's a bit like the
water it's like the watercress
yeah no
so we have a recommendation that the
cwms
waimakari zone committee received this
update for its information
i think we've advised wee bit on local
community consultation needs
can i have a move in that direction
please
erin thank you seconder dave
all those in favor
assumptions can be dangerous
it's a good assumption right thank you
carried
thank you
item five which is the ocean outful
compliance update for wdc and
who have we got here
gavin welcome good afternoon everyone
um today i'm presenting the uh
the eastern districts scheme um annual
monitoring port for 2019 to
2020. uh report was delivered to the uni
committee in september um
that included the uh compliance report
that uh council staff have put together
in summary the we comply with the ocean
out for consent
um on all our conditions
in 2019 to 2020. um
since that report went to unr we've
received confirmation from the regional
council that it
has complied with all consent conditions
um the plants operated um are operating
well
um where obviously i'm taking
maintenance every year to ensure that
that continues
and um the consent it doesn't expire
and there are only these upgrades
planned um in the next eight years uh
between wood end and the uranus waste
water in plants to ensure
we continue to meet our consent
conditions
so i'm happy to take any questions
caroline um i just wondered
one of the um michael bates who comes
and talks to our committee every month
brought up crikey must be three years
ago now about
um diatom foam
on the beach down at pine acres and
he can undertook to do some testing to
determine what it was and whether it
could have been related to the out four
um and i just wondered whether that ever
got done
or i know there was difficulty in
actually getting down there when there
was some foam to collect
um well you managed to get two samples
yeah there's two samples undertaken um
and i've got my own viewpoints on this
but i'll just check with
sophie there yeah you come up um and
then i'll also add to that one sophie's
just gonna update on
great so there was a research by levi
esr
a few years ago where they tried to look
at the diatoms with the
so basically the green algae
they didn't actually manage to get sea
foam at all when they were trying
they took samples from the sand and from
the water
but obviously we're limited by not
having foam
yep so and i
just remember that i didn't they didn't
find any levels of concern
of um fecal bacteria and it's we also
do regular weekly sampling as part of
our ocean out for consent we do do water
sampling
and we often if ever have had any
problems with levels of
of bacteria but what i have been doing
last few
two summers is trying to get samples of
foam and i've managed to get
both the whole unit and myself managed
to get one sample each
the problem when i say there is often
foam on the beach of a small quantity
but the
volume you need to collect which will
bubble down to something they can
actually measure
for bacterial content as they need to
have at least
100 mils they can filter but that's a
large volume of foam
and so when you've actually managed to
get that quantity
there have been levels higher than what
you're under the water
higher than what you'd be able to swim
in but what i've
uh said to uh in my reports i think to
the utilities and roading committee was
it land and water or
unr both okay so in reports to council
at least um
what i think is happening in the sea
foam is that you've got it sitting on
the beach
in warm conditions because often
summertime that this foam is being
produced and it's like a greenhouse
effect where you've got nutrients
and heat and you do have bacteria
multiplying
with nutrients it might be a phenomenon
that you see
anywhere around the world irrespective
of whether you have an ocean outflow or
not that you do get high bacterial
numbers
the other process apart from bacterial
replication
is um there's evidence that bubbles in
the sea
naturally can pick up the bacteria in
the water and glue them together
in bubble scavenging and that's so with
those both those processes combined
yeah i think what the next step that's
probably beyond what our council could
do
is that is see from a bacterial source
wherever you happen to be around the
world so
it's getting to the stage where that's
not something our council can pursue but
it's something i've been meaning to talk
to the university of canterbury see if
there's any student who like who would
be interested
to carry on that study
so could i just add to that as um so
from the wastewater tree implants
out to sea um if you look in the
monitoring port
our bug numbers are away far below the
consent limits
and interesting although i don't
wouldn't like to use this defense is you
look what comes out of the waimakariri
river that we also sample
were substantially below those numbers
and just in there
the ocean out full the design of it is
that
the low numbers we send out as soon as
it exits the hour 4 was diluted by 75
times within
it within a few meters and then as it
goes further it's dilated further
um every five years we'll take a study
undertaker study which is known as a
benthic study
where um we engage nowhere to go and
take samples of the seabed
and they they've been taking those
samples prior to the ocean outfall
being um put in place so that's to
ensure that
we monitor that we're not changing the
environment and today there's been no
um no nothing's been picked up so the
next one's on
20 22 in march
so from from
you know what we are we believe we you
know we're putting
um very low bug numbers out to see and
then they've been diluted
um my personal opinion is that you know
the ocean out full is not related to the
the foam but obviously
we ideally would get some sort you know
further scientific backing on that
thank you i guess we should pass it on
to michael at some point in time
shouldn't we
yeah it's a shame he's not here to hear
that given
so i have been in contact with so with
the reports from they have gone to our
wdc committees they have been circulated
to michael bait
thanksgiving um you know i had a couple
of things i just wanted to touch on but
you've covered them already with your
consent going out to 2038
so what is the predicted population
growth of this district
about another 20 000 by then you're
comfortable you can accommodate that
yeah in the last 18 months we've done
two studies
one on hydraulic capacity and the other
one on treatment capacity
obviously the question will raises
around well what those consent
conditions will be in 2038 yeah so
changing
the environment at the moment um in
terms of you know uh there's
been a focus put on three waters and one
of the key focuses will no doubt be um
waste water
coming up in the future
cam sorry perhaps more of a scientific
question just so i can understand the
graphs
a lot of the fecal coliform and e coli
graphs that sort of bounces along the
bottom most of the time
and then it'll just have an astronomical
spike every so often
what's what's going on there why is
there such big swings in that reading
so that's um
certainly the fecals um
have been reasonably stable we we do get
what we probably refer to
as an outlier um
but you know excuse my pronunciation on
this but the
not the e coli but the inter montero
cockeye
they have historically particularly
around march february
we have had some random spikes in those
numbers
and over the last um i think six years
council has
engaged um esr and a consultant to look
into that
um so it's within our consent limits
to have those odd the old spikes but
obviously we're not happy about it
um we believe it's that particular one
particular bug
um we believe it's it's it's it's coming
from
within the pipe itself we have uh what
we call a biofilm
so this at this stage we've been into
the our pipes just recently and we've
seen the biofilms quite thick
so we believe that essentially um there
might be some
bug counts sloughing off those walls in
that march period that water temperature
changes so as when the water
temperature changes something's
happening inside there so
what we're only taking in the next six
months is to clean those all the
pipeline lines
and we'll do uh to get that biofilm off
and then going forward we have a regular
flushing program to make sure that
biofilm doesn't
build up obviously when we clean that
off we'll be sending that back to the
trim plant
not sending that out to sea um otherwise
that'll be picked up on the benefits of
a no doubt
um so that's that's our theory
um but with those high accounts we still
comply we're allowed
six high counts a year but um obviously
we just don't like to
have those current
cam are you looking for the job to clean
out those pipes or europe
so yeah again just coming back so both
wood end and
kyboy rely on wetlands for a filtering
sort of process
do you need to expand those areas as our
population grows over the next
20 years expand the wetlands
no the the uh the main emphasis
on increasing treatment has been through
aeration basins essentially it's a
large basin pond that we have aerators
installed to um knock down
the loads coming into the plant the uh
the wetlands um
the planter wetlands uh i refer to them
probably more polishing
um they'll see there for the cultural
reasons but and they do
provide a minor treatment
but we have um uv in front of those
so you know in terms of uh reducing bug
counts we don't rely on them
so we wouldn't need to expand them to
uh for a to to meet our
treatment requirements um going forward
thank you any other questions
thank you very much for your time sir
thank you everyone alrighty
uh that was item
five that we come back to it
so we have a motion that we receive this
update for its information
and with consideration to its priorities
and community engagement do i have
a mohs mover thank you caroline second
up wendy
thank you all those in favor
against carrie thank you
murray you have the chair
thank you michael
the first item is has been
custom for some time proposed plan
change seven
um most of the the summary there
is consistent with previous months the
critical thing that most people will be
aware of is that the hearing
has begun on the 28th of september
and carries on through over five weeks
not consecutive weeks through to the
fourth of december
so that process is underway now and i
don't know if there's any
questions or that anyone would like to
ask
um i think it can be viewed because
um it's on youtube yep with um
with the panel chair dave shepard being
locked
down in melbourne it needs to be
zoomed so um it's actually viewable
day by day on youtube as david said so
that
gives an opportunity for people to catch
up and get a sense of
what the submission process is like what
the hearing process is like
and i've included the the links which
will also give you
access to information in those links as
well
the next item we've got is the the
regional committee
uh and that's coming up next tuesday
caroline is that correct
so i don't guess we don't really have
anything to update but i'll hand it over
to you
no agenda yet so i'm not sure what will
be coming up
um hopefully we'll have a bit of
direction perhaps on whether
regional committee's heading in terms of
its function
um yeah but if anyone's got anything
they want brought up
just sing out
i believe that's right in terms of just
from what i've heard around the office
yeah that that's part of what that
sessional
will feed back to you as committee
members as kind of
options around what the regional
committee might look like in the future
potentially so
um there's a bit of a gap in the in the
meeting papers which was
really around we would normally have the
land and water committee there but we're
slightly out of sync with the way those
meetings going given that that's is it
next week sandra or
later this week this week so we
because that committee hasn't seen what
it's about to receive
at the time that we put these papers out
we removed it so
we can provide that for the next meeting
in november
so that makes item three um an update on
the
committee's working group so i can
perhaps hand over to to cam
and judith and carolyn just uh they've
provided
a summary update in the um in the papers
but
um perhaps came if i hand it over to you
i don't know if there's anything else
you'd like to add or
any questions that there may be for you
no i probably got nothing to add
unless there's any questions
thank you um can you um outline what the
planning and research into this wetland
silverstream wetland project
involves and also can you
explain what a a land care group
is and how it differs from any other
group
thank you uh sure so let's start with
the
silver stream wetland project so
uh that was i guess one of the key
projects that the len q group was
looking at
um targeted projects for improving water
quality particularly from a farming
perspective or landcare perspective
um we've had a meeting this was a
meeting with referred to that was
friday two weeks ago in kaipui
really discussing if we were to put
targeted approaches around
the headwaters of silverstream what
might that look like
and uh really we came up with a lot more
questions around the sites that might be
required for that particularly if you're
looking at wetland construction
targeted stream augmentation given the
unique nature of silver stream that
essentially it doesn't have
defined spring heads that really the
whole thing is a spring head
for probably kilometers
so our discussion centered around what
what science is known what is unknown
where where we might pick up
um further research and advice around
what the options might be to fix the
water quality particularly those
headwaters where the nitrates are the
highest
so that's where the research was uh
component was coming in from there so
there's quite a long list of
options and ideas that we came up with
in the meeting that
will plug away it before we start
looking at any
any potential concepts there
does that satisfy that question
[Music]
yep sure who was doing all this research
and
knocking around so at the moment it's
sitting with
the i guess the lanky group as a
subgroup of the zone committee so that's
what they can support
um i guess it's envisaged that if the
language group is becomes what we want
it to be which is more
community farmer driven a a large-scale
catchment group i guess you call it
that eventually once the group is formed
in a more formal sense
that that that group would pick up that
research in any projects that might come
from that with the support of the zone
committee nikken
but for now given the timing mostly with
pc7 rolling through we haven't been able
to
formalize any land care group that will
happen once pc7 is rolled through
that at the moment this is still sitting
within the zone committee
in terms of time frames there really
isn't any
it was quite a long list of of research
and analysis that needed to happen first
so
we really can't give any indications on
time frames yet
and the other part just around the
landcare group itself
i'm learning uh very quickly what the
various terminology means so
i understood a lanky group to be quite
extensive in terms of its catchment that
have
i thought of catchment groups as being
quite a defined group
of people around a specific water body
in a landcare group being more extensive
across multiple water bodies apparently
that's
talking to joe buckner is the other way
around the landcare groups are much
much smaller so whether that name
remains i'm not too sure
essentially it is around a large scale
catchment group that embodies
the majority of the of the zone um that
is driven
by the landowners or the various
stakeholder groups rather than by
council or by
uh by the zone committee so it is a it's
in conceptual stage whether it stays as
a landcare group it might be
a next generation of the next generation
farmers group
um it might be i know looking at
amalgamating a lot of their catchment
groups in their zone
whether this ends up being something
similar to that we're still unsure and
it probably won't have more direction
until
we've had our what they call it a um
a forum that's right where essentially
we chuck everyone in the room and say
look we'll understand what the issue is
what do we want this to look like where
is the money going to come from who's
going to drive it and
that is all going to be post pc seven
because all those groups are currently
involved in submissions and it's
probably dangerous for us to discussing
too much given that process is going on
so hopefully that'll be done uh well
assuming the hearing's finished on time
will be by the end of
yeah sort of april may we've got a
meeting a foreign
schedule hopefully for november but
that'll depend on whether the
everyone can make it at that time
if there's no other questions of cam i
can hand over
to judith for biodiversity working group
okay
um well there's a as you we seem to be
out of kilter between meetings
and this meeting i think we might
address that next time um
so as it says in the agenda we um
we were going to meet we did meet on
just last thursday
with um peter joyce and letitia lum to
discuss
the idea that kakariki trust well to
learn about tayara
trust the work they do how they're
funded etc
and they work in selwyn to plant trees
i will provide and plant trees through
volunteers on private and
public land and we were looking to talk
to
whether or how something like that might
work in waimakariri district
um we've discussed that again today um
in the workshop prior to this meeting
and i think really the main decision is
we'll just keep talking to the trust
about how it might work here and perhaps
talk to some individuals
and to waimakari district council as to
how
a biodiversity community trust might
work
in this district i don't know if any of
the other members of the committee have
anything to say
you've got a summary to summarize it
thank you
thanks judith
and carolyn you've provided just uh that
quick update that the um
excel will create catchments on tomorrow
yep so
hopefully by the end of tomorrow night
we'll know what our name is actually
going to be that's sort of like the
interim name
um i know yeah so we're just
sort of doing very preliminary things
like deciding on a name
um landcare could be quite popular
working at a vision
a vision or some goals looking at our
structure
and seeing if there's interest in um
what projects are out there like for
fencing and riparian planting whether we
can
pull anything together in terms of going
for some funding
um yeah and and what activities that the
group are interested in pursuing
um areas of interest we've had
an offer already from ray onyear who
owned
ashley forest to for the catchment group
to go up and
have a field day up in the forest early
next year to see what their
their environmental management involves
and how it could be impacting the
catchment
and one of the local lifestylers has
been out in his digger i don't quite
know what he's been doing but he's
he's been fiddling around with his
swales and doing some pretty cool things
he reckons so
he's happy to have everyone over to see
what he's doing as well
so yeah so it's really cool the way um
things are just sort of you know
starting to even at this early stage it
feels like it's getting a bit of
momentum and
it'll be interesting to see if if we get
a similar turnout tomorrow as we head at
the first one
fingers crossed yeah yeah it might be
yeah and joe
thanks carolyn yeah that i think it is
great that you you're getting that quiet
sort of momentum just within the group
itself so yeah that goes well
tomorrow if there's no other questions
around that we'll
we can move on to the next one which is
uh communications and engagement and
angus has provided in the papers a link
to the the key article that that's
emerged in the last
between meetings um
and that is around um some support of
the a project
associated with next generation farming
trust so i don't know if there's any
questions on that or if the angus if
there's anything else you'd like to
to raise at this point any other
breaking news
um
[Music]
thanks angus that's probably quite a
good um
update relative to the next item as well
really um
the the links that are in there i think
a bit like pc7 will be consistent
um links that i'll provide each month
because
um in angus or i'm reinforced that
um particularly to the ecan site that's
where information will continue to be
updated
angus isn't it so that's the link to use
uh in an ongoing way
are there any questions around that
either of those
yeah please um in number five
the committee will receive briefings on
this package in due course
and i just wonder if we could actually
get something sooner rather than later
given this
stuff already on site i've already had
been at a
zoom workshop with an ecan presenter who
presented what she could say at the time
as an update and we could actually
discuss
what is a wetland you know when is a
ditch not a drain and things like that
and i just wonder if
we could have some intermediate or
interim briefing
sooner rather than later
might want to i don't know if he wants
to to speak to that but certainly
after i um submitted the papers
uh uh at the end of the week we saw the
first sort of i guess uh
an outline of an approach in terms of
getting something to all of the zone
committees by way of a briefing so
it arrived after these papers were out
but um as angus has alluded to
a lot of works going on certainly to i
guess firm up positions one of the other
things that's come through
when i scuttled off across the the
building to follow up on that was that
um and
and certainly that it's right to put the
plural around briefings because
um and as you've intimated judith you
know getting something in the near
future but
it certainly won't be in any way a
definitive or final
briefing that there's so much to i guess
to digest and get
our collective heads around that
there'll be multiple briefings over time
i think
for committees useful things about this
zoom meeting was
i think on the ecam person said it was
interesting or useful
was that we asked questions that she
hadn't thought about or
i mean i guess the faqs are going to
start popping up but
we were ecologists and we were asking
questions about interpretation of
certain
terms from an ecological perspective as
to planners and i think
again from a community farming
perspective
we might be able to ask some questions
of a person giving a briefing that
they can answer and take forward
um from my understanding and we've
um sorry i we probably with the fed's
head on have
have asked for the same thing around
briefings and um
and it's the area it i can only expect
from what i've heard this is not from an
ecam perspective but
um that yeah they're still trying to
work through every summary we've
received and i think every summary
they've given has been more a summary of
the documents mps and nes itself rather
than how it will
apply in canterbury um so we're getting
yeah questions sticking fast as to what
do i do in my scenario where i've got
this and that
and and then council saying i've got to
do one thing and the mps is saying i've
got to do another and
i think it's just yeah there's a lot of
scenarios to work through
but i yeah the sooner we can get some
answers the
yeah definitely the better because
there's a lot of questions out there
a lot of questions here yeah no i'm
this probably isn't a question you can
answer and guess or not at this point in
time is
i just wondered what if he can't have
given much thought to how they were
going to engage with the community
because the mps specifically states or
in the
fpp process which is the freshwater
planning
process i think i've got that right that
it's community
and local roanoke that decide how the
mps applies within
your region and i haven't heard any
any mention from anyone with any can
that's given any briefings about
community engagement
thus far
certainly part of the engagement plan
the runanga part of it is big
tamannaah obviously so we're starting to
get our heads around that
and then we're breaking it down into
sector groups
including the wider community i think
it's fair to say that will probably
become a little bit later because the
demands as cam said are coming through
thick and fast from those on the ground
farmers and others and groups like
yourselves
zone committees so it's uh it's a lot to
bite off
um and yeah it's not just going to be
ecan either i mean there's a lot of
industry groups that are doing great
work and we've already spoken to dairy
nz
and others about how we can work
together with them to get
good faqs out there and also some
alignment if we can if we can manage
that
so um oh sorry no
i guess um i guess where my concern is
coming from is that
more emphasis emphasis has been given to
the runanga proportion of it
but the statements the sentence that
says
community and runanga it doesn't put one
before well
the sentence puts community before
runaga but it won't be putting rooney
running his wants above the community so
i think that
the balance hasn't been struck yet in
the plan that's been put in place thus
far
uh early days and i'll certainly take
that back um
it's it's not a conversation i've heard
too much so far but
again early days so that
and i guess i'm just my point is that
for 10 years under the canterbury water
management
strategy the zone committee has been the
representative of the community on water
management
in the region across the region in this
district
and so we will be we are we're set up
to bring the community and roonenga
together and i think we should be a
well off the list of people getting a
briefing
we have a project team meeting tomorrow
so i can certainly take that along to
them very timely
i think folks i think that is timely um
that's probably where the timeliness
ends and the updates um i've just
in terms of the zone committee review of
sophie and
kate have just left um you will recall
at the last
meeting um which was quite a juggernaut
of
a meeting and two workshops and a
follow-up meeting
um on the day um the follow-up meeting
uh at the end of this meeting a month
ago was just um
an opportunity for uh to look at the
zone
committee feedback on the zone committee
review
with representatives from the district
council
alongside arupata and john from arunagar
perspective and
michael and cam there to represent
the committee as well just to to review
the feedback and get any further sort of
thoughts
and by and large in information i think
of of the points that the committee
raised so
um in noting those discussion points uh
with i've fed that through
to sophie as a as a basis for firming up
what will go to the council in terms of
shaping up the letter of shared priority
so
i think that will be done in the the
coming month and probably go to
the district council in november so
um waimakariri as it's
regularly seen region wide is sort of
leading
uh the the way in which this has sort of
been assimilated and
and um picked up by the council in terms
of coming up with a um
a little a draft of a letter of share
priorities alongside what environment
canterbury's provided to each of the
each of the other 10 water zones as well
so so
yeah i think that's basically that's why
i just did a quick one-line update
that it's basically on the back of the
last month's meeting it's been fed
through to
firm up that paper um which i guess by
and large the council's already
seen so um
if there's any questions around that
um the other bit of um
timing that's not so great um action
points from the previous own committee
meetings i
i followed up by way of dress rehearsal
with adrian
torvill and dean of how we would respond
to these questions
and the only thing missing really is
adrian um
who who was following up on these points
so look i'll i'll
endeavor just to quickly touch on these
because
um we have got and in fact tim
who's also not here he's done a wee bit
of follow-up in terms of like the law
information and getting that updated so
he's
he's seen something through whether i
thumb on my throat or whether we
circulate at all
yeah so um
the other items that we just touched on
there i think adrian like um
we've noted another uh point today in
terms of
of adrian coming back to this committee
by way over a report on the
um monitoring that's being done so i
think in and around the kaiapoi river
there's a fairly substantive briefing
there that we can do
that adrian can provide based on those
action points
so obviously they were noted as
recommendations from this committee
at the last meeting so um apologies for
adrian not being here i've been checking
your phone to see if um
um but yeah as of late last week he was
um
working on this so i'm not exactly sure
where he is and hope he's okay
uh just a point on that um well when you
find them
um can we have um so if it's
able to be emailed can we all have an
email of what he was going to present
or can we have an update about when he's
going to present it
i did can i just mention something else
on under that
that action point number seven i had a
look at the lower website
um because the annual report on
rivers has come out for 1920 with
no improvement over the last 10 years as
being the
lead-in paragraph that went nationwide
but
what i wanted to ask about particularly
for our patch
i looked at the rivers that were being
monitored um
there's sizable gaps in the in the data
um there's a new one in there wilson
drain
now is wilson drain line side road
it's called it's not yes
so it's new it's got on it it's a new
one and i just wondered whether
um because no one was left here from
like jared's gone as well who perhaps
might be able to
update
let's go to kokino yeah the wilson's i
thought came from then
is it lionside road drain because i
thought they were going to stop
that you reckon it's over that side
okay i was going to ask about that but
the other the other
thing that is clear to me is the gaps in
the data
someone needs to look at it i mean
there's water quality in these
um ecological readings
need to be brought to this committee
because or
have a have a report because part and
parcel of those zipper recommendations
is updating on monitoring
and if there's still gaps um they need
to be addressed uh
for a start the in a well a simple one
which um gets up my nose all the time is
the fact that
um we called
the kaipo river upstream of three
streams
silver stream and it is still referred
to as kuiper river upstream
now is it relatively simple to just put
brackets
silver stream because there is a
distinct
change kaiba main stem it doesn't
get any water quality it only gets a um
it only gets the fecals over the the
song period
now that's another issue that clearly
adrian has been asked to
look at which was the substance of the
discussion
um last time so i'd like to see
that if our input into what goes on the
lower website is through
ikea and obviously supplying details
can we have some sort of briefing about
um i'm particularly concerned about um
silver stream um
kaipou river and and the tributary
streams
that go into the the kaiapoi so can you
note that and see if we can have um a
bit of a discussion
uh whenever whenever adrian reappears
from uber
you know that's that's um and i guess
that it falls into line with the
zipper as well i mean we literally had a
recommendation around that didn't we in
terms of the
naming of the the upper and the lower so
um so yeah look i think that does sound
like something we can
introduce into the into the site so
we'll note that sandra thank you so much
sort of on point there um certainly
uh having followed up since the last
meeting with both adrian and tim they're
they're looking at that and and they
were and have followed up with the newer
folks in terms of those two sites and
and they continue to do so just to to
make sure that they
are updated so i think that you know
that forms a basis upon which
what sandra's just asked like can we
also update some of the
the way in which the the data's
presented or
waterways are labelled should be
something that he can can
so between angus and is two people in
the room here that uh
associated with this committee and and
engagement around this i think that
is public information that's something
we can follow up on
but we'll obviously do it with our
science colleagues um
given it's their responsibility as well
sorry just um following on from sandra's
comments um she'd also
sent an email and reply to one of
judith's emails around
trying to get a localized version of
that annual report which i thought would
actually be quite
useful to see is that something we are
able to
check to see if that's an easy way of
collecting that information on a
district basis in terms of from the law
yeah so the lava report's got a
nationalized whole lot of bar graphs
that show on a national scale
how water quality is shifting across a
number of metrics
um just wondering if they've got the
statistical ability to do that in the
background whether we can
or we can we'll look at doing something
like that
for each of the zones on an annual basis
if it's just a mathematical
i think again i think that's it you can
do them all individually but it's
apparently they ask them to do
yeah you can come up one by one but it'd
be great to see
overall are we improving yeah look
that seems a valid and it would make it
a useful resource for each
yeah not just for you yeah
yeah yeah so um and tim
yeah yeah yes absolutely look i'll one
i'll follow up with i think tim's
probably done some work
looking at that aspect but but it is a
um
again it could be just a structural
thing in terms of how they
can um group and collate um so
a valid point for us to follow up on
take that as noted
um following through um
the other action points from the
previous meeting there was the um
a briefing to be arranged by the
district council around the natural
hazards and hydro
dynamic modelling um and
and following up with sophie and that
where we identified because
we thought the november meeting would be
a good uh opportunity to do that just
with the fact that that's
underway so well we've got that
effectively
onto the agenda for november
and the other or the final update
uh point there around the tree removal
at the the rakahuri regional park near
rangiora
david owen had provided um that
statement
for us which is included just giving a
i guess a follow-up i guess from the
original
situation in terms of what's been done
since then so
i don't know if there's any further
questions around that
let's ask councillor stewart
if um the uh the plan the recreational
master plan
um how's the mayor's support has that
come to council at all yet
no no okay
thank you so much
yeah i think david saw that even if
linking it into
the braided river revival thing i think
that that master plan is seen as
something
which is a really good way for
environment canterbury and and the
district council to work together on
that
on that regional park area so i guess
it's a way of picking up
what's happening with the tree filling
and turning it into something
um positive on a slightly larger scale
as well
as a recreation and amenity area for
rangiora
okay that's lovely
thank you murray we will follow up on
some of those points
next month perhaps indeed yeah well
they're more than points as
yeah they i have
a recommendation that we receive these
updates
for its information and with reference
to the committee's 2020 2021
work program and engagement priorities
can i have
a mover please
thank you dude of second uh david thank
you all those in favor
against carried
item five confirmation of the minutes of
the previous
waimakariri uh water zone committee
meeting which was held on september the
7th
uh and that they are a true and accurate
record can i have
a mover please david second up
judah thank you all those in favor
against excellent carried matters rising
sorry um we skipped the discussion
matters are rising we haven't we're
wrong no it's not a matter of rising
it's actually correction to the minute
sorry oh it's a
question about the minute so let's go um
and i think you
use a you presumably listen to a
recording of this do you
type it okay so i was just going to
question what i said but you probably
got a better record than i did um page
biological monitoring on the banks of
the kaiapoi river
i actually thought i'd talk said the
whole of the kaiapoi river but
um if you use the recording i'll pass on
that
thank you just forget it that's right
yep that is
if that's what i said
any other matters there folks
corker um i've got one just coming back
to
page five uh
when we had a bit of a roundabout in
terms of which was new territory and
plan change seven
so
owned to the fact i had a gap in my
school holiday program i went to the
hearings first day
which after i left at the end of it i
thought maybe i should have gone
mountain biking for my children but
anyway
the first piece of evidence that was
presented by ecam was their legal
submission it's quite important you'll
have a look at it if you haven't already
um basically it's saying
this plan change must give effect
to uh the freshwater package so that's
that's a game changer
for us and our community um
so just have a look at that when you get
a minute um but that's
that's the basis the hearing's
proceeding on
so um yeah
that was the one thing i picked up on so
must give effect is quite strong
terminology
um also later on a week i did hear
submissions from tim carlton farms which
i thought was well presented
uh dairy nz gave a very good
presentation that effectively stood
behind a lot of pc7
to almost 2040 and their estimate
estimates that estimation um
so there was um a lot of interesting
comment
that you know knowing the background it
is worthwhile if you get time to go
along and just
sit in the background sometimes you've
got to sit on your hands and
not try and put your hand up and make
comment but um yeah
you're hearing both sides of the story
and it's um
it's the right forum for it
[Music]
do we have any other matters arising
well um i have quite a bit of
um question about
the stuff that we mentioned last time
particularly on page 77
and i guess i was expecting it would all
be coming
with adrian and perhaps tim's update
so i'll park it but yeah
concerned about all the things that we
discussed
and i expected it would be addressed in
a report
so really keen that um
that that does happen that we get a
report on this
um another update land and water
committee
on thursday will be dealing with our own
internal
report on the kaiko river which pulls
out a lot of stuff that's
that's here
nothing else excellent
item six general business
everybody's looking like they've had
enough
nothing there corker
if there is no one who has any press in
general business
um mr rubin could you honor us with the
carrick here just to close the meeting
meeting folks is at this on the 2nd of
november
can we november can we have it here do
we
have it somewhere else
that would be most appropriate if we
could have it at the rotatofa center
and copy and if if you could check with
that together
we would be uh quite excited about that
because
you can look across the river to the
portent eagle hello thanks very much
[Music]
you